I've spent the election campaign
traveling around the country I've
already been some marginal seats in
Grimsby London and Scotland to try and
get under the skin of the election and
this week on the final leg of my tour I
headed to Cheltenham it's a conservative
Liberal Democrat marginal seat so
exactly the kind that Joseph Winston's
party really needs to win chastening in
Gloucestershire famous for its Regency
buildings and luxury shopping streets
it's also the home of GCHQ Britain's
biggest spy agency the Liberal Democrats
held this seat for 23 years until the
Conservatives took it in 2015 now they
hope to win it back I'm sure there will
be a lot of tactical voting obviously
here in Cheltenham there's a lot of
Liberal Democrat voters in the first
place but there's going to be a lot of
tactical voting in this election I'm
sure at the beginning of this election
Joseph Winston was saying she thinks she
could be Prime Minister mastery well at
the moment it looks like the most likely
outcome is a Tory minority government or
a Tory majority and the important thing
is that people know that by voting
Liberal Democrat we're we're in Tory
facing seats you can deny the
Conservatives a majority in this
election I'm not meeting a huge number
of people who who want this in children
you know Boris Johnson government backed
by Nigel Farage that is something that
German people are telling me that they
are very worried about for very many
reasons in a seat where 56% of people
voted to stay in the EU the Conservative
candidate Alex chalk is battling to keep
his seat so how confident are you that
you're going to retain the scene well
it's on a knife edge but I have to say
the messages I'm picking up on the door
really really positive and people
recognize that actually we've we've so
many people Wreckers we've got to move
forward and that's it this paralysis is
causing such damage to our country so
there's a national position people want
to move on to all the other issues which
are important to us here in Cheltenham
like our ane or schools or hospitals or
climate change which I'm really
passionate about how does Boris Johnson
the man who fronted the campaign to
leave go down in this seat any leader it
is mixed but there is a there is a lot
of team leaders more than is known of
course of course that's right but there
is a quiet section of the public who are
sitting there going oh my goodness at
least someone is trying to move this
forward Labour admit this election is
more about increasing their vote share
than actually winning the seat
so how optimistic are you then going
into the selection I think there's a lot
of positivity and a lot to be said for
for labour at this election in
Cheltenham we've grown our vote sure at
the last two elections and we're
certainly looking at doing so again this
time and actually what I would say is
given the number of non votes in each of
them there is a very real prospect that
if they did all vote for us yes it's a
sort of wild scenario then possibly we
could see victory but even if we don't
we'll be growing our vote chair and
actually looking ahead to 2024 2029 and
the Borough Council elections in May and
how does Jeremy Corbyn go down on the
doorstep Jeremy Corbyn I think has
actually seen a rise in popularity
throughout this campaign because people
see that while he may not be the
traditional leader we've had lately and
a sort of more presidential direction
our politics has taken he is a capable
manager of a cabinet and he is able to
manage those competing powerful and
strong and intelligent personalities in
the labor cabinet to build a consensus
which will work for the country as a
whole but what did the voters think here
so I mean you know to be honest I think
I'm more aligned to Labour's policies
but in Cheltenham we've got basically a
you know a choice between a Tory or a
liberal seat and so my my overall
overriding feeling is that just want the
Tories to be out it's a pretty asset
again he's such a nice bloke alex chalk
indeed alex talk is such a nice bloke
and he has done so much for the town and
the trouble is I would like to vote
Labour
I would vote Lib Dem if there was a
stronger leader are you planning on
baiting for conservative and why is that
because I think Boris Johnson would do a
good job even though he's a maverick I
think he's got good policies and
basically stands tends to stand behind
what he says he's gonna do and try and
deliver it which for a politician
basically is a rarity I am very
concerned that Jeremy Portman might get
in which I think would be tragedy for
the country I don't really like Jason
because she seemed to think she had it
in the bag by you know just just saying
the saying in and not offering a
referendum which I think it was
for her party I personally I would like
the Conservatives to stay in I'm not a
massive Boris Johnson fan I'll be honest
before I came to chant them I thought
this seat would be a shoo-in for the Lib
Dems a remain voting constituency where
the party has a history of winning but
after spending the day here it might be
tighter than I first thought
and for a party that started the
campaign promising that Joyce Winston
could be Prime Minister that's a concern
if the Lib Dems are to have the election
breakthrough that they had hoped for
seats like Cheltenham are a must win
with less than two weeks her campaigning
to go this constituency could still be
up for grabs